j'apprends que vous avez fait une
émouvante demande en mariage sur ce
plateau
pourrait-on savoir quand fatto a prévu
de passer de la théorie à la pratique
ça avance à grands pas ah ouais ouais ça
fait quatre ans goût dit ça je peux pas
vous dire plus ça avance à grand grand
grand val d'oise claude
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mam était réfléchie rené questions du
public quelle qualité isabelle acte
votre femme n'a pas assez mais ça ne dit
les pauvres ils répondent apprécierez
qu'isabelle elle commençait à
l'autoritaire bien pour son abbaye label
c'est mon ami donc d'accord et bourg et
bal à isabelle a pris une claque boy sur
le dossier valérie benaïm toi qui
connais tous les chroniqueurs depuis des
années lequel a pris le plus la grosse
tête
ça peut être un chroniqueur qui n'est
pas là non plus dit l'amérique elle-même
se réfléchit le couple grosse tête
ah ouais vraiment vraiment vraiment un
peu ouais c'est vrai ils arrivent ils
arrivent le dernier où plein dans le
plat ouais c'est vrai que ça va réclamer
par le public aimerait sur marquez c'est
vrai mais bon c'est mes remarques
humilié d'arcade et dar k mais il
embrasse très très fort derrière
l'oreille à la semaine prochaine notre
raymond clément garcia question
inclination du public avant pour cracher
sur tvm paix maintenant vous y
travaillez comment expliquez-vous ce
retournement de veste on va expliquer
comme vous m'avez interpellé en 2017 sur
twitter parce que j'avais et critiques
étaient pmp mais je vous dit très
gentiment bien sûr maintenant yannick et
arras s'est très bien passée il avait
demandé à me rencontrer sur paris dont
c'est vrai on s'est rencontré dans une
brasserie vous avez payé du bien et donc
en side mais voilà on a continué à se
parler pendant plusieurs mois
j'aime beaucoup et voilà et je pense que
ça se passe bien j'ai appris à vous
connaître j'ai appris à connaître
l'émission j'ai appris à connaître les
chroniqueurs et j'ai changé d'avis mais
c'est vrai que voilà j'aime bien savoir
pourquoi les jobards ict est vrai que
j'appelle sont gentiment en plus
maintenant
franchement j'attendais je vais pas dupe
attaque et clémence et non pas dans plus
est maintenant vraiment je le dis on
s'adore franchement c'est même
franchement mes études je peux compter
sur moi en plus je sais que voilà il le
sait qu'il peut compter sur ma vie
j'essaie vraiment parti
oui faut pas qu'ils jugent voilages et y
avait claqué au bout du bar faut pas
juger
géraldine maillet imaginons qu'au studio
prend feu qu'il faut sauver notre
chroniqueur lequel tu ne sauve pas et
dire arrête tu peux même être
l'animateur tu peux pas me sauver ce
tueur ben je vous sauve pas parce que je
sais que vous êtes tellement fort vous
allez réussir par vous même bien joué et
bien joué
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai marre